do you have any guesses who the vice
president okay so
a day or two before i went off the grid
politico leaked out that it was going to
be kamala harris and i sort of felt that
was like a little too obvious even
though he said it had to be a woman
and we know he said it has to be black
did he in fact say it had
a woman of color oh so it could have
been elizabeth warren could have
obviously yeah
exactly
you see that a little bit in the
reactions to the party conventions yeah
oh the party convention the party
conventions happened they both
biden biden's alive biden uh
technically i don't i mean that's at
least what they're saying yeah so biden
is still the nominee he is my nominee
yeah i'm still
i'm still do you have any guesses who
the vice president
okay so a day or two before i went off
the grid politico
leaked out that it was going to be
kamala harris and i sort of felt that
was like a little too obvious even
though he said it had to be a woman
and we know he's the senate has to be
black did he in fact say it
a woman of color oh so it could have
been elizabeth warren could have
obviously yeah
exactly um about a week later and now
that now i have
was off the grid already i was uh in the
fruit section i was buying a melon
actually
i do enjoy a little watermelon in the in
the summer months it gets hot here
and uh and there was a woman likes like
screaming
in joy uh about kamala harris so i
suspect
that it is kamala harris i'm guessing
it's kamala harris the way you're
nodding at me sort of
it is kamala harris she is the worst she
is the worst she is the worst i mean she
is the worst do you think she is the
worst do you think
would have helped him or hurt him in the
polls do i think that kamala would help
him or hurt him
well it can't really well first off the
polls at this point it's like who knows
what the polls mean
it can't really help because the
democrats hated her nobody voted for her
nobody likes her
and and the the crazy lefties that are
running the show right now the antifa
bernie
coalition of marxist lunatics they all
hate kamala harris because they think
she's like a corporatist
sellout but she ugh that's so gross
it's so gross and it did you know look
she's the worst she's the worst kind of
authoritarian
yeah you remember that moment at one of
the debates when she was still in it
when the question was asked to uh biden
about would you use an executive action
to ban
assault weapons or do something on guns
yeah and biden said
people can find this biden said oh it
would have to be constitutional
and kamala harris looks at him laughing
and she says
joe can't we just say yes we can
and it's like wait a minute you think
that you can use the power of the
executive branch to supersede the power
of the legislative branch on something
that's enshrined
in the constitution yeah like she's the
worst
oh it's funny you mentioned that witchy
cackle because
you'll remember this is the big problem
when biden picks her
she launched the most vicious attack
against biden
that has yet been launched this cycle
she she called him a vicious racist
at those early debates and said he was a
segregationist or whatever right oh
right
remember that the bus stop and all this
thing so
she goes on the colbert show and colbert
to his credit pushes reese's uh
uh senator harris what happened to joe
biden being a terrible racist
and she she puts on the cackle she goes
it was a debate and so he says right it
was a debate but
but you know are you saying you were
lying then or it's not he goes
hahaha it was a debate it was a debate
it's called a debate it was a debate she
must have repeated the word and that's
how evil these people are that
that's what i'm talking about yeah it's
all becoming too
obvious to him yes yeah the the nonsense
she never believed he was a racist no
one in their right mind believes joe
biden is a racist
but then you throw it out there and it
and and for anyone that's on the fence
about politics that's that's watching
this happen it's like
when you see them do it against their
own and it's a lie does it make you
wonder when they call everybody else
maybe it's a lie too
right but this stuff for some reason it
just sticks to conservatives more
than it does their own but wait so tell
me about that so so the polls are
they pick a lot and you know you pick a
vice presidential candidate your polls
are supposed to go up that's the point
of picking a vice president
balances the ticket maybe you win a
state but it's got to help you
the poll numbers went down so even
democrats were deeply dismayed by them
because who
who likes her who likes her she was one
of the first people out in the primary
nobody wanted this woman to be the pick
and
so this ties entity politics ruins
everything it touches period
including your own base of support yeah
right it's like even the democrats kind
of made this faustian bargain with like
okay we'll do this identity politics
thing
which is obviously evil and contrary to
logic and yeah but at least we'll get
more support
maybe for a little while but you go in
so first is the dnc yeah and the rnc
followed oh okay
okay dnc worst produced
thing i've ever seen yeah you would
think democrats own hollywood
wait and was it live or not it was some
of it was live
so live meaning they had there were
people oh no no no
all of it was it was a zoom call it was
the only question is were they was it
actually going out live
or was it did biden get out of the
basement or did he literally do it from
the basement
so he did he actually did somewhat well
in his
acceptance speech he slurred some words
but that's par for the course yeah uh
but he was barely in it he was barely a
part of this thing it was all this weird
zoom call stuff i actually want to do
two truths and a lie with you right now
just before we get into the dnc
okay okay so you tell me which one of
these
is the lie okay the dnc
removed the phrase under god from the
pledge of allegiance
ugh that feels true to me because
they've been trying to do this for a
long time
okay they booed god remember it was a
2012. yeah
okay so that feels true that feels true
hillary clinton urged americans to
respect the results of the election
no that doesn't feel true to me it
doesn't they they want even if it's
biden even if they think biden's going
to win
they they're setting it up knowing that
biden's brain is going to
explode or something but she doesn't
want people they they haven't done it
for four years yeah these last four
years so that that does i guess
well like no i mean i suppose i could
envision a situation where she's
tipping to the people you know if our
guy wins let's make sure he accepts it
right i guess it's sort of pole
dependent right
it's like it binds way up in the polls
and don't forget when you went off the
grid biden was way up in the polls we
can maybe get into that a little bit too
okay
one of my neighbors in the new house
does have a joe biden
uh you know a little placard in front of
his house it's bite in sunglasses
and it's got the american flag in each
eye is there anything more contrived
than the stupid biden
aviator thing i wear aviators he's
ruined he's ruined aviators it's so lame
yeah third one trump brought peace to
the middle east
i like the way you play this game
knowles that seems more
legit to me than the democrats
respecting the election if trump wins
but i'm going to go on the assumption
that that is false okay
um so so then you got so that you've got
these three
dnc removes under god hillary clinton
says respect the election trump brings
peace to the middle east
yeah so which is the lie
well trump didn't bring peace to the
middle east
although you know i've been away for a
while knowles we live in a strange time
there's peace in the middle east there's
sort of peace in the middle east and
trump sort of
peace so there is an historic deal that
was just signed
normalizing relations between israel and
the united arab emirates
this is the first time that israel has
normalized relations with an arab
country in
at least two decades 26 years or
something this is actually
world historic news wow and of course
it's being blocked out of the mainstream
media
even if you had been in the news you
probably wouldn't have seen this
during the week because it's mainstream
media is not talking about it
so trump actually does this he gets
absolutely no credit for it of course
the under god thing yeah dnc did remove
it at the start of the
uh muslim caucus and the lgbt caucus so
it wasn't at the start of the convention
but at those two could you imagine
that's really twisted but that's not
surprising it seems to me the
the lgbt caucus i guess there's no
direct it's not like that's a religious
group right it's not religious
so all right let's just put that one
aside for a second but the muslim caucus
that doesn't make a lot of money sure
they believe in god i think they do
so they do because obviously the dnc is
now just totally secular
totally atheistic and you were right
hillary clinton
of course i love i love that it is more
believable
that trump brings peace to the middle
east then that hillary clinton says
respect the election
and not only is it believable it's true
hillary clinton went out there and said
joe biden should not concede this
election
under any circumstances not just he
shouldn't concede it's close it'll be a
little
under any circumstances it's it's so
obvious to me that the democrats invited
this evil
cancerous ideology into the house they
invited it in
and now it has ransacked the entire
place it's pulling the copper wiring
from the walls on the way out
the entire thing is collapsing and there
is
so really this is true like i don't mean
this to be hyperbolic
there's almost nothing you could have
said to me yeah
that happened at the dnc thing short of
the short of biden
burning the american flag like right up
there like hey let's just do it
everybody
um that i wouldn't have believed because
i don't
i hope maybe more people are realizing
how how
evil and corrupt and anti-american and
everything else this thing has become
yeah and and i look forward to
criticizing the republicans in just a
moment when you tell me a little bit
about what happened there but like
this there's nothing we've discussed
this a million times in the last year
there is nothing the liberals can do the
good decent liberals who are scattered
throughout the galaxy and there's very
few of them left
there's nothing they can do to stop this
thing if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell